i
hoy es un día que marca un antes y un
después para mí
hoy voy a abrirles mi corazón
para transmitirle mi aprendizaje y lo
que hoy entiendo es mi legado de vida
esta es mi historia
en el área del 2010 grave crisis
financiera en mi país venezuela
y ahora vicepresidente de uno de los
bancos involucrados en esa crisis
en el proceso de investigación llaman a
declarar a varias de los empleados de
esos bancos
la noche que me llevan a mí
para este proceso no hubo tal toma de
declaración ni testimonio que nadie
escuchara
esa noche sin más me dejaron detenida o
más bien secuestrada
que te hagan presa siendo inocente en un
país como el mío lamentablemente hoy es
algo común
en mi caso sin razones políticas
aparentes porque nunca ha sido política
no había ningún tipo de razón ni de
derecho que justificara la orden de mi
encarcelamiento
esa brutal injusticia marca el inicio de
mi quiebre personal
rabia en todos los sentidos niveles de
rabia que ni yo misma conocía yo lo
único que quería saber era de quién era
la culpa eso
en un primer periodo por el ego mi
erróneo sentido del poder del dinero y
por la falsa creencia que una dictadura
y ciertas cosas que por derechos humanos
no pudieran ocurrir
me llevaron a desarrollar una verónica
fuerte muy fuerte fría calculadora
resistente inquebrantable
un personaje que todos se creyeron
porque yo me lo creí
pero estando ya presa los días
comenzaron a transcurrir
sin embargo por decisión propia yo
decidí detener el tiempo
los días se comentarán se comenzará con
convertir en noches y las noches en más
noches
me apague deje de ver la luz
pero un sótano tres metros bajo tierra
cuatro rejas al menos
oli a golpes el jugo
olía mar muchas lágrimas mezcladas con
miedo
había celdas como en las películas pero
también había cuartos
muchos hombres intimidantes solo dos
mujeres y mucho miedo
entonces yo empecé a vivir aquello como
yo entendía que tenían que vivir los
presos bien víctimas yo rechazando me
maltratando me culpabilizando me y ese
otro personaje lo desarrolle
excelentemente bien mucha pérdida de
peso insomnio crónico adicción a
fármacos
aislamiento depresión severa
que toda la circunstancia parecía que se
justificaba que yo estuviese así sin
duda
parecía que se justificaba todo incluso
estar casi muerta
hasta que lo intente
hacemos de la realidad exterior lo que
es nuestra realidad interior tan oscuro
estemos por dentro y así de oscuro se
convertirá todo
parecía que esa verónica no le había
sido suficiente ver la muerte tan de
cerca tantas veces parecía que me hacía
falta más parecía que me hace falta
morirme
hasta ese momento mis hijas
representaban mi única fuerza interior
ojo pues son mi principal fuente de
inspiración que es distinto
no sé en qué nivel de consciencia me
encontraba
pero lo intente
en venezuela se pueden conseguir todo
tipo de fármacos dentro de las cárceles
y todo tipo de cosas
esa noche me tomé muchas pastillas
mezcladas con alcohol
no soy capaz de recordar las cantidades
lo siguiente que recuerdo es verme
vomitando sola en un catre que no
aparecía en cama moribunda intentando
que me saliera la voz para pedir ayuda
cuando me doy cuenta tenía muchas
personas a mi alrededor diciéndome pero
resiste que estas sales
y cuando me di cuenta que seguía viva
sólo tenía una frase perfora de mi alma
ya yo me salve
esa noche entendí que ni por mis hijas
ni por nadie yo sobreviví a aquello esa
noche entendí que mejoraría a esa
verónica a la que se salió la voz de
donde no tenía para pedir ayuda a esa
verónica que quería vivir aún estando
presa
y como de alguna manera esta noche
volvió a nacer
comencé haciéndolo sintiéndome muy
pequeña me obligaba a comer dos veces al
día comencé a leer cantidad de lectura
enriquecedora recibí todos los consejos
que me dieron de meditación yoga afines
comencé a hacer ejercicio físico comencé
a recuperarme porque quería vivir
sin embargo se me hacía muy difícil
sentía como una bola de hierro en mis
pies que me pesaba mucho
no podía entender como yo me estaba
empezando a sentir bien estando presa
tenía como un conflicto en mi mente
tenía que vivir aquello como presa y
muerta o presa y viva
había algo que no me encajaba
hasta que me vi
somos los principales saboteadores de
nosotros mismos aunque nos empeñamos en
ver las razones de esto en los demás
en esta cárcel donde yo estaba no había
espejos por ninguna parte según yo
entonces cuando a mí la gente me decía
has perdido mucho peso tu cabello ya no
es el mismo
tu piel parece gris a mí todo aquello no
me importaba total no tenía donde verme
yo sólo tenía un espejo pequeño de
maquillaje que utilizaba los días de
visitas
un día le pido a mis custodios que me
regalaran tres minutos más de los
reglamentarios en el baño
como sentía que yo todo un privilegio
pues decidí recordarme mis hábitos
femeninos y cuando me voy a colocar mi
crema de cara busco automáticamente
donde mirarme
y me dijo
[Música]
lo que vi fue una imagen sórdida
horrenda yo abría mucho mis ojos para
entender quién era esa verónica que
estaba en ese espejo no me reconocía
como era posible que yo había llegado a
ese estado esa no era la verónica de
aquella noche de muerte inminente que le
salió la voz para pedir ayuda
lloré muchísimo después de ese encuentro
con ese espejo
días enteros semanas quizás
pero las lágrimas comenzaron a secarse
ya que no quería llorar más en esta vida
y quienes se rinden y quienes siguen yo
estaba harta de seguir rendida que era
como estar muerta
y entonces empecé a recuperarme
realmente comencé a recuperar la ilusión
comencé haciéndolo escuchando música a
toda hora todo el tiempo todavía hoy lo
hago
recupere mi sentido del humor
era yo la que anima a mi familia a
seguir adelante para no intentar seguir
desbloqueando una situación que desde el
día uno nos tocaba vivir
comencé a conversar con mis compañeros
ya para ese momento no eran presos y
delincuentes para mí
y si esas personas necesitaban de mí un
abrazo un gesto una caricia yo estaba
ahí para dárselos me hace sentir bien me
puse objetivos en el día y si los
cumplía los celebraba me sentía bien
conmigo misma hasta pude entender cuando
era de día y cuando era de noche para
empezar a recuperar el hábito del sueño
debemos ser capaces de vernos en nuestro
propio espejo una y otra vez las veces
que hagan falta hasta encontrarnos hasta
encontrar esa versión de nosotros mismos
donde todo fluye y nada nos detiene
un año y ocho meses después que para mí
fueron como 10
donde me perdí buena parte de la vida de
mis hijas
recibo la llamada de mi madre que me
dice hija eres libre hoy regresa a casa
yo no podía entender cómo era que yo yo
me había desconectado de todo lo que
estaba fuera de mí incluso el juicio
cuando cuelga esa llamada con lágrimas
en mis ojos me susurró a mí misma yo soy
libre
ya sé sótano para mí no representaba una
cárcel
y sentí miedo de salir de ahí y regresar
a mi casa saben por qué porque esa casa
y ese entorno que tanto grite que me
habían arrebatado injustamente
representaban para mí mis verdaderos
barrotes mi verdadera esposa
regresé a mi casa y seguí presa con
custodia policial las 24 horas un año y
tres meses más
pero ahí hay el tiempo era todo para mí
me lo quería comer
comencé a vivir mi vida
aun estando presa
tuve que estar presa para sentirme libre
de vivir mi propia vida sin importarme
los demás tuve que estar presa para
sentirme libre de ponerme de primera mi
propia vida sentirme libre de sentir el
orgullo de haber derrumbado mis propios
barrotes mentales sentirme libre de
perdonar cada golpe
cada tortura cada amenaza y las que me
hice a mí misma sentirme libre de
volverme a enamorar de mí misma solo
desde ahí pude entender porque estuve
que estar presa
en realidad siempre fui libre solo
estuve presa
que hice un día para que no sueltes ese
espejo y puedas derrumbar tus propios
barrotes mentales la libertad es tu
mayor valor y está dentro de ti no
descansas hasta encontrarla muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]